سفينة تجارية كورية شمالية
من خلال غزو nll ، جيشنا
حتى بأعداد كبيرة من خلال الاتصالات التحذيرية والطلقات التحذيرية
فعل
غزت بينيل
الإجراءات المعتادة لجيشنا ضد السفن التجارية الكورية الشمالية
حول العمل التشغيلي
كوريا الشمالية
تم إطلاق الصاروخ
انتهاك الاتفاقية العسكرية بإعاقات واضحة
إثارة
استمرار الاستفزازات ضد كوريا الشمالية
الادعاء غير المعقول للعدو ليس فقط في شبه الجزيرة الكورية ولكن أيضا في شبه الجزيرة الكورية.
كعمل يضر بسلام واستقرار المجتمع الدولي
أحثك على التوقف على الفور
[موسيقى]
البحرية
كجزء من تدريب Hogu ، من اليوم
كوريا الجنوبية والولايات المتحدة في البحر الغربي لمدة 4 أيام حتى يوم 27
القوة الجوية للجيش
بمشاركة خفر السواحل الكوري
تدريب البحر الغربي المشترك